when i'm choosing a teacher some  teachers are very quick to correct  and that is useful for me at an  intermediate stage  but at the beginning stages i will be  very quick to just decide you know what  this teacher isn't working for me and i  would recommend anybody listening who  has tried to learn a language in the  past  and run into one of these the these  brick walls that the person you've  spoken to  kind of cut you off they made you feel  bad this does not mean you are a bad  language learner  this means what you did didn't work for  you whether that was the course you  worked  with or the teacher you used so i  have no guilt whatsoever and saying this  teacher sucks  cancel get the next teacher